par isabelle thomas tu à 27 ans pas
depuis longtemps d'ailleurs une semaine
et tué la benjamine du comité directeur
du parti socialiste
tu étais extrêmement médiatisé pendant
les événements étudiants de la fac 86 et
honte à surnommer isabelle la catholique
ce qui est assez drôle et c'est pas pour
rien parce que tu es devenu star en
quelques semaines sa yaris a mal tourné
c'est quand tu as fait cette photo dans
paris match on t'a vu alanguie sur un
piano avec une coupe de champagne
c'est un grand mot de trop maquillé un
peu trop quoi c'est mal coiffée à mon
goût mais
pas du tout attendu mais bon c'est vrai
que c'était un piège que m'avait tendu
l'hebdomadaire paris match un jeu je
suis content on discute indien après ça
semble se confirmer
et puis c'est vrai que j'ai pas une
propre
il ya une phrase que tu a relevé dans
avec les déclarations de principes du
parti socialiste qui est à dire le parti
socialiste est un parti révolutionnaire
il ne peut pas exister de démocratie
réelle dans la société capitaliste est
ce qu'aujourd'hui tu souscrit encore à
cette déclaration de principes du parti
socialiste non je regarde d'abord je
n'ai pas relevé trois qu'on a fait une
contribution à l'occasion du congrès de
deal avec différentes à parade où on a
rappelé cette phrase et julien dray
reviendrai on a rappelé cette phrase de
la déclaration principes du parti mais
oui je crois que moi je regarde notre
mise en garde ou simplement et puis je
suis pas contente ça me satisfait pas le
seul mais mal à l'aise quelqu'un de
justice de drames chose qui est ce que
tu es marxiste ou oui oui oui je
secret à on associait la limite pas
comme un dogme et sa femme
3com ce qui s'impose à nous comme une
bible mais comme une méthode d'analysé
comme je pense que tu as dit aussi dans
les ca c'est toi qui l'a dit c'est pas
le parti socialiste le dit le gaullisme
c'est l'anti démocratie
je suis contre l'homme providentiel ça
doit pas faire plaisir à mitterrand
quand même et je crois que ça le vrai
débat c'est un vrai débat parce que il
est vrai que françois mitterrand est
apparu notamment que dans la campagne
des présidentielles un peu quand même
mais je crois que en dehors de ses
qualités
propre il y a que les institutions de la
vème république fondent que le président
de la république qui est le seul homme
est à cette place à cette position élu
au suffrage universel qu'avec
l'approbation la majorité deltour
rectorat se trouve porté avec tes contre
l'homme présidentielle sauf quand il
s'agit de mitterrand temps non c'est pas
ça qui manque en france
non je dis que je suis contre la
providentielle par principe parce qu'ils
y compris ce soit les uns aux autres
comme un effort mais je ne
je ne pas porter la responsabilité à
françois mitterrand je pense que ce sont
les institutions de la vème république
qui fait amène à l'eau son avènement
d'accord il ya une autre affaire dont on
a parlé ces derniers temps c'est d'y
être chargé d'une mission sur les jeunes
et l'europe j'avais des bureaux qui
était réservé qui était tout près tu
n'avais plus qu'à s'installer
et puis tu as critiqué la gestion
sociale du gouvernement rocard et michel
rocard a mis son veto au fait que tu
diriges cette mission est à la baisse au
point et dans l'observateur c'est pas
très grasse
par contre comme ça que ça s'est passé
il est vrai que je devais avoir une
licence aux régionales en réalité est
que je ne lis pas eu écho que je suis
pas très contente quand tu as lu le
livre de thierry pfister qui s'est
beaucoup de souci pour toi qui pense que
tu es manipulés qui pense que tu es une
jolie fleur carnivores milieu des
plantes parasites
tu as lu tout ça c'est à dire qu à
partir du moment où on est une femme on
fait de la politique qu'il appela pour
véhiculer ces fiers de ça c'est
forcément qu'on est passé dans mon lit
dans ses missions ça ne peut pas en être
autrement
donc à partir de là la réponse tu vois
souvent mitterrand de temps en temps
c'est pourquoi on discute politique on
discute c'est un individu qui sait
parler d'autre chose
par exemple où les littératures de
le spectacle de sculpture dernière
question s'il passait sous un camion ça
ce rat quittant candidats et aucune
chance je sais pas j'ai pas réfléchi à
la question
mais de toute façon je ne pose pas de
problème je ne me pose pas de problème
en terme d' individus j'ai vite en tout
cas ses droits quel courage soit cadré à
la cour en or celikkol dans d'autres
stations c'est sûr que ça serait pas le
courant au guardian avocat d'affaires le
jour et bonnes affaires la nuit voici
guillaume faber interview vérité alors
guillaume faveur bonsoir c'est bien sûr
pas ton roi non non non je prends
vraiment sont a demandé de porter un
masque ce soir c'est parce que d'abord
publié un bouquin chez régine de forges
qui s'appelle autoportrait en direction
on va en parler des visas ensuite parce
que tu as peur que tu es que tes clients
sachent que tu écris ce genre de bouquin
non
et parce que franck et heroes qui le
fait dans ce livre je parle de femmes
l'enjeu était heureux et je voudrais pas
qu'on puisse les reconnaître non plus
enfin des camille des brigittines pas
mal quand même
oui mais enfin je donne à certains
détails qui pourraient permettre à leurs
proches d identifier donc je serai à mon
avis discours quad parce que tu dis pour
commencer le bouquin c'est que ce qui
est important dans cette
dans cette autobiographie en fait c'est
que avant tout c'est le taux
biographique tavergeux mais elle est pas
l est pas extraordinaire en plus elle
mesure 17 cm et une longueur tudyk est
somme toute assez banal oui deux fois de
justesse et dragons moyenne des prêts
elle fait 3 cm de diamètre c'est pas
terrible ne s'est pas attiré fait mieux
mais je pourrais tu dis qu'on ne fait
rarement des compliments quand même une
fois une fille qui tu as dit que tu
avais une belle que m'enfin c'est pas
non plus je sais pas ce sera après moi
d'ailleurs pour le compliment est dit ça
parce que tu es faye a bouffé tu crois
aux non pas du tout non c'était parce
qu'on allait passer un bon moment
ensemble et si c'était peut-être la
reconnaissance du ventre comme on dit là
tu dis qu'elle est fonctionnel oui
qu'elle s'adapte à tous types de vagins
d'anus de bouche qui est pas mal
finalement les assez passe partout alors
par contre est beaucoup moins gentil
pour le sexe féminin tu parles de
boursouflures tu parles de deux formes
vague tu dis que c'est que cet effet par
un chirurgien malade et vieillissant
ça vient d'où cette espèce de désamour
pour le sexe féminin mais je pense que
ça vient de ma culture moi j'ai été
élevé dans
le culte de la statuaire grecque par
exemple toutes les femmes sont lisses
praxitèle que jolie et israël est
évident que le sexe féminin à côté
attirance forte et claire quand il était
petit il a rien d'extraordinaire
ouest france ce serait d'ailleurs sur
les statuts on voit pas mais par hazard
mais il ya un truc qui te fait pas trop
marrer non plus c'est le baiser de dire
à part dans ton jeune âge maintenant tu
dis la bouche des femmes c'est pour ma
verve le plaisir en fait c'est un
substitut à la hourre aulas et quand on
peut pas faire autrement tu dis qu'on
fait des langues des langues four et des
langues profonde vous quand c'est dans
un ascenseur et qu'on peut pas baiser
quoi oui c'est hoymille d'ailleurs je
crois que je suis assez mauvais au
niveau baiser donc d'abord c'est un bon
buteur n'était pas la star du coup on a
grand besoin j'en sais rien mais si tu
parles de ton dépucelage étudie que ce
jour là avec cette chère lily tunisie
quand même leslie oui tu dit que c'était
quand même six fois de suite ce n'est
pas un peu prétentieux salle six fois de
suite
non mais ça c'est parce que j'avais 50
bouteilles et donc moins de pression
ouais le pôle performant je crois en
vieillissante un peu plus modeste qu'on
m'aime pas et maintenant hormis
nettement oui je viens du starter été
fermés quant à un coût pour retarder
l'éjaculation qui est pas mal et elle
dirige encore poids des crèmes des
machins des trucs toi c'est pas mal tu
pensais tu es facture tu prends cet
effectif qui s'accumulent sur ton bureau
ça marche
ouais ça voir souvent
alors après il ya tout un tout un
chapitre sur les sur les positions en
missionnaire par exemple en le
missionnaire
c'est le début quoi on est mobile va
t'en passer par là mais enfin c'est vrai
que le plan fonctionnel c'est pas du
tout agréable on fait moins c'est assez
lourd en plus
donc oui je le soutiens sur les coûts
d'espérance à fatiguer quant à melwood
sur les draps rugueuse oui en plus vers
fait mal non plus le corps d'une femme
est à mon avis plus au lit
dans le produit par année alors tu es
devenu à l'amoureux du dos un adepte de
la levrette je suis pas le seul à
pouvoir quelque part entre nouveau dit
peut-être pas toujours mais c'est vrai
d'ailleurs que la position naturelle
philosophie des sciences je prends comme
une bête à dire mais oui mais on était
quand on fait l'amour en fait taper
qualité une belle expression c'est la
paresseuse de choses un joli mois oui
c'est pour moi qui l'inventé je les
trouve dans un bouquin liberté il faut
que le correspond tout à fait à donner
sur le côté oui c'est ça on peut même
presque pendant mire séparer ce une
façon trop hormis andy nombreux parents
qui manquent
l'amazone des pales fanatiques ensuite
quand suis vraiment fatigué il faut que
je voie pas une femme trop fort la
masturbation par contre tu dis c'est la
panacée universelle explique nous
comment faire une bonne masturbation
imagine que les gens nous regardent sont
dans leur lit engagements de chacun tout
l'intérêt pendant dix minutes après
l'émission qui et comment ils s'y
prennent je crois que chacun a sa
manière de se masturber dillon sirugue
l'elysée la plupart des gens refusent de
reconnaître qu'ils se masturbant très
content d'en parler un peu avec eux
aussi des reason que les femmes
d'ailleurs ils reconnaissent qu'ils le
font ils en ont un peu honte alors pour
avoir des détails c'est difficile pour
moi je connais je ne suis par exemple
qui se masturber dans sa douche avec le
pommeau de la douche en réglant la
pression était un bon il semblait assez
raffiné d'ailleurs
mais elle osait dire à personne donc
chacun a sa technique je prends non
c'est pas comme l'a fait la science à la
fellation d'un grand à l'aide parce que
tu dis que finalement la bouche de la
femme c'est le meilleur réceptacle pour
la verge de l'homme désormais je suis
pas je parle de tous les hommes feront
comme moi
l'expérience prouve que tous les hommes
qui sont morts avant l'amour dans tout
morts en opération a bon les hommes
célèbres et on a vu un certain cardinal
dont on pense que ces trois jours parce
qu'avec la fondation sais pas pourquoi
le 40 à 140 et c est alors qu on est un
peu usée vannée claquée way la sodomie
dans la sodomie tu dis que c'est comme
christophe colomb quand il a découvert
l'amérique se tue la découverte par
hasard on va être un jour tu t'es trompé
quoi j'ai glissé ouais c'est vrai ça ah
oui il ya plus m'en vais d'ailleurs ma
partenaire sur les personnes parfois à
plus tard elle a rien dit oh non non pas
du tout aux locaux du plan de ce que tu
dis ça tu dis qu'au début les femmes
sont réticentes fin dans tes expériences
puis que finalement le sont toutes
d'accord bout d'un moment
oui à condition qu'on ne le considère
pas la sodomie comme une façon de
châtier ou d'être sadiki fouet
c'est un acte d'amour c'est pas dans ton
niveau qu un libertin la sodomie c'est
une façon de finir une femme était alors
évidemment ça peut être mal est une
punition
enfin moi j'ai jamais forcer personne
n'a pas deux fois et la sodomie c'est un
plaisir partagé même bien savoir
alors oui j'aime beaucoup pourquoi parce
que le rectum à une forme pas comme le
vagin il ya des choses plus relâchée
l'expliquent par hasard moi j'en ai lu
mais je recule explique aux gens qui
braveront navy mécaniquement c'est parce
que la friction sur l'un verger - en
plus qu'il ya juste le la rampe
pour cela il ya juste lisons le l'entré
deux
de l'anus quoi qu'il en soit le reste
après on est dans un grand vide
ouais donc comme ça prend beaucoup de
temps à ce que c'est ça non avant d'être
là mais je reconnais que vous faites à
facebook 1 pour apprendre aux gens pour
faire partager aux jantes en citant côté
pédagogue comme quand tu vas donner des
cours dans les écoles où c'est pour
faire du plein de peu une main non pas
du tout j'ai écrit ce livre par plaisir
personnel pour un petit peu faire le
point sur metatron faire l'amour et non
pas seulement ceux mes sentiments que je
me suis dit l'enfant les sentiments
c'est beau mais il ya pas que ça et le
reste on n'en parle jamais non que j'ai
essayé de faire un petit point à bieber
en quelque sorte qu'aucun réuni 34 ans à
l'écrire je n'ai pas écrit dans cette
page
oui justement tu l'a écrit par petit par
petit paragraphe a écrit quand le soir
en tranches étoiles mais en attendant la
crise et qui avait fait un petit
chapiteau à wenzhou
mais quand il y avait un truc qui me
venait à l'esprit qu'à pris du plaisir à
l'écrire car beaucoup de plaisir oui ça
t'a fait bander les faire se lie à oui
certaines pentes de ski à des souvenirs
et arrêté pour s'être masturbé alors oui
parfois
évitons de nous aider oui de films
bartolone comédie the book by iron man
which is rêver quand tu relation one eye
moussilou et because we were de first
jammer of the beatles anywhere fact and
replaced by ringo starr non batum east
one of the most of your story
why you will achieve it et mignot
sur ps3 et john harbour
[Musique]
connie joe bronzich inniger nicolas
l'histoire ni week end jusqu'au bord de
piste
à titre personnel il n'y a pas de lady
gaga est d'avoir su renouveau et au
respect pour ce forum est un père tual
bâlois niveau de plus par exemple
non après
[Musique]
cette envergure mann saisit netbook tout
jeune oiseau seixois de haut face à
udinese replaced by which has taquet aka
ringo starr ou au spleen hawaï où chaque
faille
m
comme la cote
[Musique]
magna
mais tout est ouvert santa cruz
[Musique]
c'est donc pour tricher
m
[Musique]
michael mann
comme en suisse ait plus de lisandro
[Musique]
m
voilà la possibilité est ce qu'il est en
bretagne dans la gueule avait pas
carbone 14
non pas vraiment madame survient
[ __ ] le trafic des stupéfiants ce
que vous avez acheté des légumes
aujourd'hui n'est qu'un on peut voir
s'il vous plaît vous avez acheté la
droite à gauche
oui vous en avez acheté combien de
grammes et à combien aujourd'hui et vous
comptez les utiliser pour vos fins
domestiques ou pour vous pour votre
entourage vous pour vérifier
rennes 20 40 madame ses 40 ans étaient
trafiqués
regardez personnel aurait trafiqué par
la secte poule qui introduit dans les
champs de carotte un produit aussi nos
jeunes qu'on appelle le lsd vous à
l'entrée du parisianisme et puis bon ce
qui vise donc à intoxiquer et à draguer
les pros des populations collective
les collectivités vont vous par exemple
vous avez vous mangé ce midi
oui vous comptez faire frapper là
passé par là dans le sac de madame
vous rappelez-vous carottes nombre du
manger non parce qu'il sait faire
non mais manger quand vers la foi
l'uni vertige santé alcaloïdes n'est ce
pas et si nos gènes vous sentez sa fille
et quinze jours ce qu'ils avaient été
soumises à élimination directe des
cauchemars des ambiances en un petit
problème madame avec vous un c'est qu'on
vous repèrent depuis tout à l'heure
votre comportement ressemble fort à
celui d'un dealer en président est-ce
que vous revendez par hasard ça
on peut vérifier que depuis quatre jours
il n'y a eu aucune altération de votre
comportement madame hallucinations
gfr
et tout ça mais madame celui sur la
santé nous sont venus un peu tous ces
trafics marchands de carottes
combien de grammes aujourd'hui madame je
crois samson g j'ai mis d'accord que ça
c'est pour une seule et même personne
une fois qu'on s'y perd dans l'aube mais
non mais je vous dis on y 2 a vous êtes
je doublais toxiques et qui se marient
maintenons nos mairies ont maintenant
une perte mais maintenant vous faites
pas d'écart au drapé votre immeuble non
je sais pour faire cuire des 40 donc
vous est ce qu'on appelle une fourmi un
petit dealer dette pendant une heure
d'entre eux ils s'intéressent de rester
ou à gauche laissait bien cet effet
c'est un plaisant aussi on a pris
puisqu'à côté là non parce que nous
célébrons du nord mena mon compte sur la
collaboration des populations civiles
si vous avez acheté les carottes qui
sont attendus tous nous aider à cesser
d'user il nous faut l'épreuve je n'en
sais rien n'est pas vendeur de drogue
opérant sur des trafics et l'arrivée
d'intercepter dans un quart d'heure
madame z nous aidez vous avez collaboré
goût les élèves qui nomme salut je viens
d'énoncer il faut coincé madame imagine
aussi quand est arrivée à europe 1 tu as
tu appris la tranche de coluche que tu
avais quand même un peu assassinée chez
pas là quand même quand tu avais dit
collige tu nous fait plus rire c'était
un peu dur quand même non ouais mais je
l'aimais ouais
j'aimais vraiment je crois que c'est à
cause de toi qui s'est remis au travail
qu'il a fait qu'il a fait ça au point
bas et non les restos du coeur n'ont
sûrement pas non mais ce que je chantais
en lui stand et reste vraiment forte
c'est pour ça que
j'ai pensé qu'il n'était pas simplement
là ce soir là à droit de réponse pour
faire son numéro mais j'ai voulu lui
dire qu'il y avait des gens qui
l'aimaient pour ce qui montrait pas là à
ce moment là mais ce qu'on se sentait en
lui et effectivement une italie beaucoup
plus loin par la suite mais j'étais pas
le seul certainement pas le seul à le
penser
alors vous allez j'en ai pas dormi pour
neuf mois après à bon alors après tu es
né sur canal+ et a fait l'un vertu du
duo le bras roulant soit fait là la
caméra visible c'est à dire que vous
voyez la caméra et chaque fois tu as vu
une excuse pour dire aux gens pourquoi
il y avait cette caméra qui étaient là
étaient aperçus que les gens finalement
il était comme tu dis cassé depuis
l'enfance c'est à dire que dès qu'il
voyait le caméra il avait été terrorisé
il faisait tout ce qu'on leur disait il
balance et leurs copains et balancer
leurs voisins ouais et c'est pas un peu
un regard pt trotskiste ouais ouais non
mais je sais pas c'est pas un peu un
regard de l'extrême car comme ça sur la
société non non je me fie plus à une
analyse idéologique mais celle du cid é
té ça vient de là quand même
non non non non j'ai toujours eu bonjour
madame
est-ce qu'on peut venir vous poser
quelques petites questions tout de suite
sur quoi venez je peux d'abord je vous
serre la main voilà comme ça bougeait
pas
vous explique je suis docteur ce tome je
reviens d'un voyage en afrique une
mission à mogadiscio en somalie
vous savez qu'il ya des ravages qui sont
causés par la peste bubonique
c'est aux commandes ça oui bon je vais
contacter et nous allons nous avons
besoin nous n'aurons pas cinq cobayes
nous sommes obligés de faire des
prélèvements d'inoculer donc cette
maladie à des gens comme vous exagérez
non non non non mais attendez il faut qu
il faut qu on discerne faut qu'on en
fabrique président africain pour la
barre donc ce que ce que je viens de
vous faire l'adsea se transmet nos
meilleurs cutanée par tous les pores de
la peau à ça les locaux mais pourquoi si
vous faites ça mais parce que vous ne
vous rendez pas compte qu'il va falloir
fabriquer du sérum en grande quantité
donc ces documents peuvent être transmis
à une réponse va prouver à tous nos
confrères européens de faire la même
chose dans leurs pays respectifs c'est
tout alors je vais vous donner ma carte
aidez vous sentirez donc les conclusions
non mais attendez
non mais attendez moi je vous dis j'ai
le sida ce que je vais faire un tel
médicament que je voyais à ce mot
l'avenant mais la scène internet
d'abord vous apprendre que vous avez pas
partir son premier cru les coordonnées
de mon cabinet mais vous êtes m'en fous
non mais attendez
attendu par tous un peu parce qu'on peut
pas vous laisser martin comme ça vous
êtes malade là bas je suis ton vous êtes
malade mais vous êtes fous alors partez
pas comme ça là vous mesdames malade
vous êtes malade
écoutez moi je vous cite à opel
j'empêche tous les gens de venir là au
moins vous ne vous ne pourrez plus
touché les gens qui est la 15e personne
on est obligé l'objet phare qu'est l'om
mais ça va partir en italie en
angleterre ils vont tous les appareils
je suis obligé effectivement de soigner
les gens dont je vous ai qu elle vous
êtes obligés madame attendait drège d'un
décor des livres cabinet sous les
chenilles ou pas voulais qu'on me laisse
partir comme ça vous allez voir 40 de
fièvre demain et ben écoutez vous êtes
sûr que je vous contacterai alors la
bombe a évidemment là j'ai trouvé que ce
moyen là si vous êtes vraiment des cons
ah oui comment on va fabriquer comment
va faire du sérum mais je ne sais pas
convaincu courbet qui devait se ranger
dans les marques et les gens les gens
qu'il faudra très convaincant
on décidera sous cette forme là mais
c'est pas qu'on va être convaincu il
faut qu'on fabrique du sérum mes
demandes et du sérum en feu en faisant
des dessins mais commence demain avant
en faisant quoi il faut bien qu'on
condamne la maladie on sent bien qu'on
contamine on va vous soigner vous
inquiétez pas ça se soigne mieux
maintenant elle mériterait qu'une seule
je sais je vous fiche ma main sur la
figure pas de façon et je signale que
c'est
les italiens les allemands le fond on
est obligé de le faire n'hésitons plus
est obligé de baver sur moi enfin il
faut bien qu'on goûte à venir
mais il tombe bien qu'on compte admin
madame vous voir n'est pas qu'on ait
laissé quand tu es parti sur sur tf1
pour faire pirates s'étaient plutôt bien
ce que vous faisiez comment ça se fait
que ce soir était aussi aussi
brutalement
je veux pas faire de délation non mais
je crois que tf1 n'avait absolument pas
réfléchi à la manière dont on avait
travaillé
nous on est arrivé avec une intime
conviction quant à elle pouvoir
effectivement fabriquer un 52 minutes
mensuel un peu livrés à nous mêmes comme
les monty python peut-être pas avec un
budget énorme mais au moins qu'on
pourrait travailler
l'imposture pour eux c'était quelque
chose de nouveau le détournement aussi
là pour être complètement tranquille tu
as fait un disque qui reprend les
meilleurs
les meilleurs sketches d'europe 1 tu
sais quand tu appelles quelqu'un quand
tu entends le à lotus et comment elles
mac quoi g si tu veux une intuition
ouais quand j'appelle effectivement des
gens dans leur halo et qu'ils ont une
fonction
j'entends leurs fonctions lalo de
secrétaire de direction n'est pas le
même que celle d'une secrétaire et il
délivre un certain nombre d'informations
que j'analyse très vite
et c'est ça le problème aujourd'hui dans
ce pays c'est que les gens ont perdu
complètement conscience de leur être au
profit de leurs fonctions alors il y en
a c'est un voyeur ce une bonne blague ça
ça fait un peu francis blanche l'a quand
même à ouais mais ça s'appuie sur la sur
la délation
ouais c'est une bonne blague sur c'est
un mec qui téléphonent il dit voilà moi
ce soir je suis voyeur j'habite en
france
ouais on est ce qu'on voit là est ce que
ce soir je peux vous mettez à la jumelle
voilà ce que mettez-vous à foix les
leaders sous dos sans pareil et le mec
petit à petit bond il refuse en plus il
prend 1
il me prend pour un de ses voisins qui
est un prothésiste dentaire qui
al'habitude de glisser par la fenêtre
dont il me vire il jette surtout quand
je propose le sens mal pour cerisier et
évidemment il ya chez très francis
blanche et la police qui appelle en
disant il faut que vous fassiez oued il
faut que vous fassiez comme ça on va
pouvoir le coincer voilà mais le mail
art en dira pas ce que lui demande de
faire le policier mais le mec le fait en
tout les mecs de fait à la fin ce que je
veux juste dire à propos de ça pour pour
expliquer pourquoi je rappelle les gens
que je me fais passer par un service de
police
c'est que je suis toujours au service
des écoutes téléphoniques est ce que tu
sais que j'ai donc avec du vent tout
leur dicte tout en continuant le mec le
croit complet alors oui j'ai fait ça 40
fois bon teint et les gens peuvent
penser les gens admettent très bien
qu'ils sont écoutés ils sont écoutés
j'aurais honte de parler de plus en plus
on les entends tu as bien l ai besoin de
régler le village de volume sonore et
les mecs parlent te racontent leur vie
dans les 42 42 complètement il ya
beaucoup d'improvisation par exemple sur
les tubes à une à 14 15
il ya beaucoup d'improvisation sérieux
quand tu appelles les gens tu sais pas
ce que tu vas leur dire c'est impossible
de savoir que je ne sais pas si je la
vois au bout du fil
ouais ce qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est si tu veux cette possibilité de
jongler avec tout qui part simplement
dus à l'eau et qui arrive effectivement
à des à des situations une folle
je sais faire que ça et j'aime
ensuite à un disque label novices ouais
les exégètes se sont mis au travail
alors il ya novice n obéissent et eux
comme c'est écrit sur la pochette mais
aussi novice n os bce s ou novalis en
anglais tu penses quoi de ce genre de
tueur on rend tous que tout ce que
bâillon effet surtout à dents dans
libération c'est une bonne question est
ce que tu comprends moi je ne cherche
pas à comprendre effectivement les
pleines pages sur toi mais c'est
toujours un peu compliqué il raconte une
aventure et il délire et c'est une façon
de parler de quelque chose tu peux en
parler avec le médecin
en décortiquant musicalement dit dans
quel musicien c'est pas mal ou le hic
c'est super ça c'est un aspect mais le
rendent légendaire je trouve ça marrant
ça les gênait personne ya toi yam ans et
liam y aura des gainsbourg et du tronc
vous êtes c'est les gens c'est bien
bah oui je suis surtout content que je
fabriquais des personnes qui
qu'ils comprennent la nuit tout ce que
je dis portes il ya quand même deux
tendances dans ce que tu fais il ya là
la ligne dure
ces play blessures cette technopole d'un
peu que l'on passé ce que tu as appelé
la cacophonie rigoureuse où les erreurs
délibéré a passé le ballon un peu
artiste me dire que un peu hard et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand on écoute play
blessures
c'est beaucoup plus classique ou plus
facile que contre les goûters la
première fois et puis à un peu le côté
top 50 voiliers pizza et a passé le rio
grande et qui était comme ça est bourré
de calembours 1 et qui a été meilleur
disque de rock de l'année
dans l'autre sens entre ces deux lignes
comme ça entre la la ligne dure et la
ligne pizza disons tout le sens où là
bas depuis depuis ben tu connaissais le
disque avant hills à yahvé roulette
russe ouais et c'était s'était pas
vraiment
une forme de tore boyau avoir quand même
c'était tout un peu ténébreux mais je
crois que ça m'a aidé à prendre du recul
sur moi enfin tu vois je tous ces mecs
qui gamberge trop comme ça que vous en
fais partie je me pose trop de questions
et puis finalement on sait bien aussi tu
vas mais ça me permet de bons de sourire
temps en temps c'est cher indices comme
ça à produire normalement ça doit pas
être cher je trouve que le dernier a
coûté trop cher un avis combien la toile
je sais pas peut-être 80 75 bref un truc
comme ça mais il est si ce coup je
trouve ça scandaleux
longtemps il faut rendre combien pour
rembourser j'ai pas peut-être 80100 me
arrive comme ça oui
ce envisageable
oui bah je vois ont correctement des
algonquins hissel s'est pas fier de
compter tes contacts quand tu étais
petit noir j'ai failli d'être considéré
comme un leurre match mental
bah c'était un mec qui était sur des
rails parfait pour lui tu vas et j'ai
joué j'ai fait un stage chez péchiney
une fois qu il fallait faire il fallait
faire un dossier pour passer l'examen
ce rendu compte à quel point c'était
parfait pour moi et j'ai eu un refus du
chiffre total est et je n'aurais
peut-être pas dû avoir un refus
systématique du site jusqu'à plus riche
que lui soumet pas rendre le métier de
ton père boulanger
non j'ai taquiner un peu quand j'étais
petit parce que j'étais un peu à l'hydre
est dédé
des gâteaux pour les mariages d immense
gâteau il est trois fois plus grand que
moi j'avais des pourboires et puis parce
pas non plus rester dans la farine
non le pétrin d'une sortie ouais et quoi
est-elle en alsace ben mes parents de
pas mal de difficultés à un d'hydra
parise avait une petite pièce vivent
répartis chez la grand-mère de service
et ça par coeur
un petit village bon c'est pas facile
d'être de nulle part
tpb bendahmane ac sacré détruit
familiaux un peu qu'on ait les blues je
te piquent une tempête merci cap et a
fait pas mal de galères quand même c'est
vrai que tu as été producteur de dick
rivers oui j'ai fait ça pendant que
maman c'est super mais abandonner tout
que d'être sur le devant de la scène
le climat s'y prêtait pas seul le seul
darche qui avait fait des trucs ses fans
avec quelques arrivées dutronc c'est bon
une période
très variés t il
dans un de ses membres de sens c'est pas
le moment le plus dur à cette époque
c'est que tu voudrais plus jamais revu
je vivais avec une femme
c'était pas possible ouais je crois que
c'est qu'est ce qu'elle pensait qu'au
fric et
moi je moi je pouvais gagner de l'argent
à travers une passion
je pouvais pas me dire maintenant que je
gagne de l'argent et la passion des
rapports est humain et j'avais ça en
tête je pouvais pas exister autrement si
je sais pas si c'est très égoïste ou
quoi mais artiste comme moi j'étais
comme ça tu vois je j'essaie de faire
plein de jeux de jobs et rien ne dit
rien de décoller ou moyen de le réussir
cette voie alors je trafic est un peu à
gauche à droite tu fais des communes
musical je faisais on faisait des cover
l'époque
d'autres artistes vécu quand il avait
débuté les plus grands succès de johnny
hallyday par exemple jouer avec sa photo
est chanté par billy schmid tu vas et
c'était toi qui disais ah ben moi je
faisais les voix rauque euh ouais ouais
de change de l'euro parfois cet ennui
quand on dit qu'elle est géniale idée de
la new wave c'est un peu c'est un peu
théorique pour pour moi mais ça c'est
peut-être pas complètement
l'armée s'est pas totalement faux
certainement parce que mon gars
à commencer par du rock comme me l'a pas
payé pour ses mandants la musique classé
que lui à ce moment là il ya des moments
télé j arriverai jamais ah ouais ouais
j'avais je n'avais rien à [ __ ] de me
réveiller le matin puis un jour ça
allait tellement mal que je me suis dit
c'est là que tu découvres que finalement
tu peux pas descendre plus bas et tu le
commenter quand il a vu que rendre la
visite dans la province et le classique
mais c'est vrai c'est pas des conneries
maintenant tu tape un peu le look la
mine bien le dire
je t'appelle
ben tu viens à la télé nous parler de
ton petit arthur qui va être bientôt si
c'est là que le petit lui oui mais je
pars faire revenir là dessus c'est vrai
dit comme ça c'est pas gênant pour les
fans est moins 10 troy
non je crois pas parce que je j'ai vécu
vraiment cette période là c'est parce
pas comme si je racontais des histoires
de science fiction tu vas et je souhaite
à personne d'être de plus de vivre ça
dans cet état je crois qu'il faut y
arriver
d'une autre manière on peut y arriver de
toute manière si ce n'est pas forcément
facile
y'a un moment 82 tu disais face et c'est
je crois le moment tu tu es séparer de
bergman pendant un moment oui et tu
disais j'étais à deux doigts de la mort
c'est à dire quoi ce nom vous savez que
gérard jour j'aurai tant surpris en
suisse
comme une star comme ça vous a fait la
clinique ensuite la clinique en suisse
tous parfaitement réglementaire et
maintenant tu vois plus du cas du café
et de l'eau là c'est pareil
moment où tu sais que tu as fait ton du
problème ouais j'ai goûté on doit pas
mal de trucs et c'était bien
alors j'ai vu le médecin il te dira un
jour avec good tu t'arrêtes de plus
crade et puis voilà tu pas faire comme
quinze jours
je parle
oui il gère beaucoup moi et j'avais
beaucoup donc
dans une machine qui marche pas le
disque d'un novice tu diras quoiqu'il
ait pas bon c'est les gens qui sont pas
bons ce qui est important c'est de jouer
d'accord l'excellent bob je vais bien
j'ai fait d'accord non j'ai pas
totalement blad mais ce qui me paraît
plus important c'est d'être d'abord
d'accord avec cet album et ensuite on
verra
quand idée
des stades avec 30000 personnes il
paraissait aussi est aussi dans le
contexte ces espèces de fêtes estivales
d'été quoi où on raconte encore tu pas
50 60 des personnes sur un show voilà on
fait il est arrivé où on a fait des
spectacles en plein centre de la ville
de québec puisqu'on parle du québec où
on a rencontré chez pas quarante cinq
mille personnes
ouais ya un espèce de magie où on
arrivait que les motos comme ça j'ai
mélangé si tu veux un peu limité qui
mena les enfants avec les frites tout le
monde ne leur demande pas de poudre ou
alors on m'oublie où on parlait alors en
79 berger plamandon ont proposé
starmania oui tu as refusé mais dit
qu'est ce que c'est cette comédie
musicale français teddy réforme
ouais mais ça quand je prenais pas
tellement à l'époque cgt j'habitais
berline woodstock dans l'état de new
york est j'avoue que je m'éclate et un
peu mieux tu vois à faire une espèce de
musique comme un crack est plutôt que de
faire des comédies musicales
j'ai pas tellement été un enfant de
l'école du spectacle avortée de la rue
c'était pas voulu non pas vraiment par
contre est venue à paris enregistré le
business man oui parce qu'à l'époque
j'avais reçu donc le téléphone qui
m'offrait de faire cette chanson je vais
demander vous voulez me l'envoyer quand
même histoire que timothy nommé vient à
paris ça tombait bien j'avais besoin de
soins de vacances je suis venu écouter
ça m'a plu c'est une chanson qui va
beaucoup changer beaucoup plaisir à
l'enregistrer bon et maintenant bon
c'est une île un tube énorme en plus
parfois au canada fois est la bonne
c'est un hymne à la vie culturelle et
ami de vous reconnaitre
à tel point d'ailleurs qu'ils ont jamais
fait la relation entre starmania
l'estadio ramon d'accord alors 82 tech
des problèmes
faut faire dire
ça m'est arrivé à plusieurs années ça
donnait un peu plus cher que tu avais
fait mais je disais on dit je me suis
trouvé à la mauvaise place au mauvais
moment
ouais et donc ce que j'ai fait je me
suis fait prendre ces idiomes il ya
seulement une chose qu'on peut pas faire
dans la drogue ces serpents oued et tu
t'es fait prendre à consommer c'est rien
oui non non ils disent beaucoup ça
dépend qui on est on a un peu fait un
espèce d'exemple ah ouais c'est plus
cher on prenait beaucoup beaucoup
j'avais fait quelques pas dans un sens
et était une espèce de sauvetage malgré
moi ouais enfin compte que le clash ce
truc vachement arriver ça nous a un peu
sauvé la vie ouais ça fait un peu jean
vial où je ne savais comment ces jeunes
pas vraiment ça dépend de ce long non
pas vous dire des choses qui pour moi ne
sont maladroits mais pas la paix des
braves gens moi j'avais dans ces cas là
les premiers voiliers l'héroïne de la
cocaïne et de mélanger donné beaucoup
beaucoup
et finalement je pense que randy à cette
quantité la sécu très drôle dénonçant
une espèce de renouveau merveilleux le
but all que j'ai fait si on considère
que je pense amis quand même certaines
avant de revenir de tout ça mais ça a
provoqué des ratés dans ta carrière
c'est à dire par exemple on t'attendait
sur scène par ivan tard par exemple à
cause de ça non je crois que je pense
que je pense que j'en ai les rien à
faire
c'était pas très préoccupée par la
carrière je m'étais jamais été un orage
et arriviste je métier maintenant
d'ailleurs on engueule encore beaucoup
choix même si je suis plein de relier
juste encore j'ai quand même gardé cette
ses côtés pas le temps de m'en [ __ ] de
deux jeux pour moi la liberté l'âge est
la chose la plus importante au monde
c'est ce à quoi pensent exemple là j'ai
écrit ces fabuleux s'agit finalement de
se dire j'ai fermé la porte à clé ouais
ils n'ont pas on va en faire mais je
vais pas être nombreux dans un cellule
quand on n'est pas beaucoup
avant on est tout seul ça au canada et
tout ça sur deux ans
si on passe quinze jours à l'heure lors
des sangles ce les groupes
thérapeutiques
oui alors justement parlons groupe ira
petit que c'est vrai que tu as fait une
énergie ce que j'ai donné aussi dans la
vie c'est quoi une thérapie de groupe
c'est un peu base et si on veut sûr j'ai
13 ans y est comme comme méthode tête ya
un endroit qui s'appelle d'étape à new
york en plein centre d'appels mise au
point c'est à dire par la suite à la
fenêtre
tu vois que tu vois des jeunes qui dans
le parc pendant que toi tu es empressent
de désintoxiquer alors c'est assez
génial comme
comme école famille combien de temps
pour désintoxiquer la main au génie je
crois qu'après quatre mois c'était quand
même assez nette
mais j'avais quand même fait deux ans
que jamais dans une espèce de décision
d'arrêter auto il pense que c'est très
facile avait plus qu'à l'extérieur
ah bon bah au début un peu donc sans
doute que tu as décroché en maître oui
parce que j'ai mon choix ça coûte très
très cher en toi aussi haussé 4,5 fois
plus cher qu'à l'extérieur
l'approbation c'était coup après
l'approbation elle est encore mal et non
parce que l'approbation n'avez pas le
droit de quitter annonçons real n'ont
jamais droit d'aller aux états unis
avant la part cela prend soin de venir
ça les drogués canadiens croient que la
vallée du lot si on doit devenir enfin
je sais pas c'est comme on aime à droite
par le journaliste effectivement je suis
rassuré on était à 8 noeuds commence par
des voleurs de sacs à main mais c'est
une expérience fabuleuse g propres
j'ai pas vécu ça si tu veux avec
amertume gênant au bout de tout ça
j'ai raconté d'abord des gens qui ont
vécu des choses beaucoup plus dur que
moi et ça a été quelque chose de
fabuleux
une fois j'ai terminé évidemment parce
que pendant votre lui c'est un peu du
foie c'est passé tout son talent je
souhaite à personne mais l'époque où tu
en connais tu as laissé du temps posions
away
les moyens sidérurgie a engagé un disque
d'or et de flatteries millions passée
alors tarp et blues du businessman avec
des nouveaux musiciens c'est quoi c'est
qu'on appelait à une autre approche du
siceco la seconde chose c'est vraiment
quelque chose de plus il sent que c'est
plus bourgeois ouais c'est beaucoup plus
mon concept aussi j'ai un peu dans ce
sens que je me faisais déjà dans les
spectacles il faut dire que dans le
contexte de la comédie musicale c'est
quelque chose d'assez statique très dur
comme ça qui m'a avec le personnage
je pense que le dise que va donner
beaucoup plus forte émotion et plus et
10 kw a beaucoup aidés gratter tout
waouh
hier et les envolées les rescapés seul
jean-françois est aussi le guitariste de
richards le guitariste pachoud présent
j'aime comment a par ailleurs la danse
dans une espèce de tour ou c'est spécial
le concorde lafayette mais je me sens
comme un jeu je glisse cet acte c'est
comment tu fais pour tous et de la dope
à paris je regarde les autres
ouais bah si tu en parles
je vois regard me theeten on était bien
il a péri
il est maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
explique une porte parole de l'artiste
of corse
you are good match alors qu'ils ne le
shop angus reid
[Musique]
chiffres nationaux vidéo l'artiste je ne
verrai où l art ou manager vidéoclip ce
nom des soins
[Musique]
le second album to call of west les
sexes et sculpteurs de fastweb
i think i was mieux c'es t elle what you
did you go to russia indien de etienne
et voici
[Musique]
les looney tunes 12 go 8 go nous
écoutent leur guide
cette box motion code mc sur imagined à
taïwan minutes mais mékinac la blague
des douanes total mais battu relance
album de sade johann hay trimestre je
sais d'où je toussais l'été dernier
c'est jackie et united states à john
collins easter on y cite octobre jack
collison
[Musique]
m
m de béton de boston
paris une witch ou c'est comme un boulet
par la crise
staying alive
your sister lifting andy foliot john
glenn beck 6 tonnes de riz fasting 2002
m elle m'a dit don't miss the fun limite
des problèmes a réduit de cette manne
pour de l'astronomie
mariani est une manière bien l'entendre
dans le londres thalys différentes
familles assistanat dyson racing over
you are in spite barras comme ça
j'attache beaucoup d'importance
aux accessoires vestimentaires certes
par exemple que j'ai fait et ça me
tentait pas trouvé ta veste jaune
c'était quoi américaine puis fera qu il
va falloir jouer le rôle voilà et je
n'étais pas conscient maintenant je
cherche un truc quoi ici j'ai évidemment
armandie des normands un jour par hasard
ou choix
et là tu vois pas que chapeaux ceintures
sur le oui monsieur je vous suis un peu
largué comme ça après ses 40 ans du
chapeau sous le maillot de mu c'est que
philips était magnifique a écrite jégu
ya la possibilité du chapeau si on
regarde le film revient qu'ils pouvaient
être utilisés n'importe comment
et moi je me fais un un seul reproche
tant sur la plan il ya trois plans ou où
je vais mal utilisé
mais je pouvais ne pas le mettre du tout
vous pouvez le mettre tout le temps
jacques y est attaché à une fusée c'est
qu'ils aient vous mais je rame on sait
vous montrer et mon garde et ils vous
donnent tous les possibilités possible
de possibilités nouvelles ni comprise ni
ailleurs
souvent ceux qui l'ont pas non non ça va
jusque là et alors la ppc qui a chialé
blanc alignera véronique genest un janot
j'essaie de ne pas obtenir le meilleur à
l'école je suis très partagé
les partenaires fantastique mais il
avait omis un formidable il ya des
partenaires
oui mais toujours attachant que je lui
prends le 17 févier au sénat un journal
ou un ami le cas de la part de quelqu'un
qui en fait partie
ça fait un peu plein dans le rhin
voix enfourcher un grand film pour mieux
plaider content bonjour j'ai un grand
film foutez moi la paix
tu es là pour ton nouveau disque qui
s'appelle de bleu blanc vert
c'est exact parce que comme tu l'as si
bien dit pour le bicentenaire on aurait
pu en profiter pour changer la couleur
du drapeau grael bah oui parce qu'un
sang impur 15 cents impur abreuve nos
sillons max c'est une phrase iranienne
ouais mais quand même il ya quelque
chose c'est normal qu'on fait c'est les
droits de bonne foi ils sont ce que marc
webb
mais sinon le rouge du drapeau je n'aime
pas en plus s'il est censé représenter
la fraternité autant prendre le vert le
bleu tu sais pourquoi ce que ça signifie
d'un drapeau français
sa voix pour moi voulait le bleu blanc
vert les couleurs de la terre moyen que
je vais pas te faire un historique mais
lui sur te connaissant que ça rapport
avec leur voile non c'est le blanc le
roi pour le bleu c'est paris trahissait
sa alors le versé pour l'écologie donc
on peut pas dire que tu es franchement à
rebrousse poil de l'air du temps quand
même non mais ce qui va se passer c'est
moi je parle au niveau individuel je
suis pas comme les égaux les écologistes
qui parle au bout
vernon en face qui très bien aussi
certainement mais je pense que ce
mouvement est là pour durer puisque si
du repas on est mal donc mais l'album
c'est pas ça uniquement
non non on n'en retient que ça c'est
déjà pas mal mais c'est vraiment été
décidée par faire des choses concrètes
pour l'écologie par exemple
non pas du tout mais c'est des couleurs
de la terre me plaisait bien pour
l'album j'ai eu beaucoup d'albums aux
couleurs de la ville
hélas est pas si je change un peu
d'optique bien j'ai toujours eu ce côté
campeurs revient ici à pleuvoir ouais
hein
ouais ouais je peux le dire hi hi fi des
temps modernes bac touba bah non c'est
pas backs et avançons vers ça ouais bon
sens versa couvrons la vie d'un côté un
peu plus calme un peu plus tribu et puis
une façon il va bien falloir meubler ce
temps quand on va arrêter un peu de
consommer on va pas aller ainsi on veut
protéger tout ça on va être obligés de
freiner riz poisson féroé tous n'ont pas
croissance zéro croissance 3 4 a besoin
tout ce qu'on a non avant non il
faudrait massogui science et aucune
retenue dans le nécessaire
et puis supprimer le super et le succès
des missions alors à tuchan qui dépasse
alors tu sors tandis que sous le nom de
jean louis aubert est maintenant une
cause de l'air dont il y d'abord
téléphone emmanuel cauchy de l'air
bientôt ce sera au baer holding sa a
ouvert ses os est au vert mais ça c'est
décision du nco si on va on a trouvé que
c'était pas spécialement valorisant pour
le hac
faire un plein cours ouais et que tant
qu'à faire il a rien dit là qu un os qu
il a il a même proposé et les autres si
donc en fait la même base que plâtre et
simon west le groupe a pas changé donc
on a dissous son chant famille tombe
juste qu'on change pas de groupes autant
changer non utilisés le studio comme un
instrument c'est ce que tu as dit c'est
à dire que tu as produits toi même plus
avec un ingé son kit a été recommandé
par les rites à sakai effet l'article
l'album des rita c'est ça qui a mixé à y
participer
il ya plein de gens d'ailleurs il n'ya
pas l'héritage on se dise non enfin
c'est vrai que cela fait un groupe avec
eux non ouais il va ouvrir les traveling
wilburys français ce qui s'est passé
récemment c'est qu'on s'est vus
des nuits entières et qu'on est qu on a
joué ensemble gaga avec axel mon
catherine attendait un heureux événement
il y avait main en difficulté 7 6 me
c'est exact dit non quand tu les
téléphones tu vends des six cent mille
voix quand tu fais enhco subventions
20000 alors là tout seul tu me fais ce
que tu veux rendre convient par exemple
tu essayes de faire une déduction
mathématiques 5
d'abord avec anouk aujourd'hui un peu
plus de cent lundi ouais mais je pense
que ce que je vais m'installer que je
suis là pour rester regardez bien
attention ça ne fait pas avec le
formateur a écouté avec lui maintenant
il faut vite rentabilisé parce que tu es
parti pour faire un simple avoue t sap a
coûté très bon non tu leur as a pas
coûté le prix d'un double album du tout
la preuve c'est que je peux m'imposer
que ça soit il un central c'est moins de
100 pour garder dans les magasins c'est
le prix d'un simple album c'est pas un
double album d'ailleurs j'ai rempli le
compact disc arabe
j'ai quand je t'ai dit il dénonçant
comme il est très bien à celui ci tu
prend une dimension non sérieusement
quand et qu'est ce que je t'ai dit avoir
lundi que c'était très bien
à bâbord le sang et elle ressemble le
plus au fond devant son vrai nom il
évolue la savane palier quelle franchise
serait alors pourquoi voilà vous voyez
vous foutez de ma gueule pour le son
c'est vrai que bataille
c'est vrai que et j'ai vraiment aussi eu
le loisir de profiter des gens qui
étaient avec moi vraiment il n'y a pas
eu de gênes et pas eu internet
parce qu'en fait qu'est-ce que je
trouvais ces produits sont aussi c'est
comme des papas c'est à dire c'était
beaucoup des mecs tu pouvais passer tes
nerfs dessus par exactement où leur
répéter cent mille fois par jour tu es
sûr de ses biens et alors donc je me
suis dit ça s'arrête nombreux problèmes
et une fois que j'ai bien vu qui avait
personne
je me suis qui responsabilise exact
nantais père de famille et je me suis
découvert déclaré hier des qualités qui
me hante a dit le travaille en fait dans
mon boulot
le vrai travail c'est surtout la promo
parce que ça monte mon âme
c'est pas bien la salle aa
[Musique]